[inaudible]
joining me today is the editor
of human progress dot Oregon,
a senior policy analyst at the Center
for Global Liberty and prosperity.
Marion Tupe. Welcome to the Rubin
report. Thanks for having me.
I am very excited to have you on. Uh,
we've met once before, uh, for, uh,
dinner.
Uh,
but what you're doing with human
progress I think is just spectacular.
You guys are actually promoting good news.
There is actual good news and good
things happening in the world and it
seemingly a is something that
people don't often talk about.
So I think you're doing great work and
we're going to spend an hour talking
about a lot of the good
stuff that is happening. Uh,
but I always like to start with
a little bio on people. So, uh,
tell me a little bit about yourself. How'd
you end up working for human progress?
Well, I was bullying, uh,
behind the iron curtain and what it
was then a communist Czechoslovakia.
And so,
uh,
from early age I started to understand
the importance of political and economic
freedom. Oh, we hit neither, um,
in regular and it pretty quick,
Huh? That's right. And then, uh,
when the wall came down in
1999, uh, me and my parents,
uh,
went for Christmas in Vienna.
That was the first time that you could
actually leave your country and you could
travel abroad, uh, as a family.
Uh, how old were you at the time?
I was 13. Um, uh,
because before then, uh, people
still could travel to the west,
but they would keep the, the, the, the
children behind as far as stitches.
But now that the wall came
down and comes in, collapsed,
you could travel anywhere he wanted.
So we decided to go to Vienna.
And the moment that we crossed the
border into a Western capitalist liberal
democracy,
uh,
it was like stepping out of a
black and white movie into a,
a color film. Uh, everything
was just so much beautiful,
so much more beautiful.
Um, the shops were full,
people were smiling, that was
color everywhere. And, uh,
so I think that even at
that early stage of my life,
I started to think about
what makes countries rich,
what makes countries poor. And that's,
I think where my interest in, uh, in,
in all of that started.
Really.
Yeah. Tell me a little bit
about your, your education.
Well, I, uh, went to high school
and a undergraduate in Johannesburg,
South Africa of all
places, uh, because, uh,
when the wall came down and my
parents emigrated to, to South Africa,
they are medical doctors. And so with
our expertise was, was needed. Um,
so as a kid I got to see both the
fall of communism and also the fall of
apartheid, which is kind of
a unique experience. And, um,
I'm very glad I had the kind of
childhood or upbringing I had. Um,
and uh,
so I,
so I finished my undergraduate at
the University of Witwatersrand in
Johannesburg and then I went to do my
master's and my phd at Saint Andrews in
Scotland. Um, yeah. Well,
what's it like being in these places when
something is falling like communism or
apartheid?
Because we seem to live in a time right
now where a lot of people think that
we're watching parts of the
west kind of fall. And you,
you've seen some stuff fall. Yes,
I think that, uh, for the vast,
vast majority of the
population in Czechoslovakia,
clearly the fall of communism
was a tremendous blessing.
There was immense amount of optimism,
um,
about the future and also unavoidable
disappointment with some aspects of the
Utopian future that people
have imagined. Nonetheless. Um,
just about anybody who analyzes economics
and politics in central and eastern
Europe over the last 25 years
concludes that people are much,
much better off than they used to be.
And I think the similar thing was
happening for a vast majority of South
Africans, especially black South
Africans who never had a vote,
who never had political rights or
most political rights and are partied.
And of course, in 1994, um,
so Africa held its first
multiracial democratic
elections. And as a consequence,
there was also a tremendous
amount of optimism, again,
followed by the inevitable
disappointments as reality set in.
And nonetheless,
it's an extraordinary time of
enthusiasm and optimism and tremendous,
I think, um, sense of
brotherhood between people. Yeah.
Do you think that's necessary?
That sort of Utopian vision of when things
are changing that everything is going
to be magically fixed and better.
And then as you're saying,
then there's that period
where you go, oh, it didn't,
everything didn't magically
get fixed at once,
but you sort of need
that vision to get there.
You sort of need that to
kind of see in the distance.
I think you appeal to a Utopian vision
of the future as you consolidate,
uh, democracy, uh, in,
in, in the case of, um,
in the case of Eastern Europe and as
you consolidate multiracial democracy in
the case of, uh, in the
case of South Africa,
but ultimately utopianism
is the great enemy of, uh,
of, of human progress. Uh,
because I think that human
progress needs to be,
needs to be measured in terms of the
past rather than some sort of a utopian
future. Human progress is an
incremental, uh, process, um,
where you are trying to decide,
okay, is today better than yesterday?
And if so, that is progress. Um,
but the problems are going to be
with us forever. The question is,
are we actually improving incrementally
in important areas of human wellbeing on
daily basis? Is that
one of the, with how we
ingest news? Because I was
telling you before we started,
like I went on human progress this
morning and it feels good to me. I mean,
the layout of the site is great and you
and the images and the colors and all
that,
but like seeing so many consistently
good things trending that you don't see
anywhere else. And we're going to,
we're going to get into many of them.
Is that just,
is it hard to get clicks
because people don't like the,
Oh,
things are a little better than yesterday
and a little and the long trends when
they just want the day to day
craziness and headlines and all that.
Yes. Uh, I,
I wouldn't be the first one to
point to the nature of news. Uh,
the fact that news is about things that
happen as Steven pinker who always likes
to say,
you know,
there is no journalist standing in the
middle of a city that he's at peace
saying, you know, I'm here in
a Luanda the capital of, um,
whatever it is a on goal, I think. Um,
and there is no civil war. Uh, you know,
journalists go to places where terrible
things happen and they report on those
things.
And so that gives a secured image
of what is happening in the world.
If it bleeds, it leads. I mean, that is,
that is a well known phenomenon combined
with the nature of the social media.
Certainly I think that, um, uh,
Twitter and uh, and, and smartphones, uh,
make terrible things immediate
and intimate. So, uh,
you know, we were able to watch
tsunami in Japan in real time.
We saw destruction and death of
thousands of people in real time,
whereas, you know, a couple
of decades, a few decades ago,
and certainly few centuries ago,
you would never have known that a terrible
thing has happened on the other side
of the world.
Does that complicate your work?
Do you think that that people get
information so quickly that then maybe are
making misjudgments because they're
not looking at the sort of long view of
history?
I'm not sure if it complicates things
because pessimism is part of human nature.
Um, it's, uh, it also enables us to, to,
to respond, uh, to these
stories in a quicker time,
uh, to be able to say, uh,
on our website at least.
Look, it is true that there
was, in this particular case,
um,
tsunami and people have died.
But look at the longterm
trends in terms of, uh,
people dying and property being damaged
due to extreme weather events or natural
catastrophes. And the train
is, the trend is declining.
So we are also able to use the
social media to, to respond to it.
Um, the, the, the problem is that
good news doesn't get picked up,
uh,
as often as the bad news
because the bad news leads,
uh, the, the good news doesn't, yeah. And
there's just a psychological component.
There might be an evolutionary reason
we focus on the bad things maybe for
survival or something to that effect. Yes.
I'm John tooby and [inaudible] cousin.
He dies from University of, uh, is it
southern California? At Santa Barbara?
Yeah. Um, they are, uh,
they are the pioneers of,
uh, of evolutionary biology.
Uh, they believe that our
brains have evolved, um, in, uh,
at a time in tens of thousands of years
ago when the world was just a much more
inhospitable place than what it is today.
Um,
the world where there was
omnipresent danger from, uh,
other tribes from wild
animals, from poisonings, um,
and, um, um, at a time when
life expectancy was very low.
And,
uh,
they like to say that our modern
skulls house and shunned minds and we,
and,
and the kind of psychological responses
that we have evolved for tens a
thousands of years ago,
um,
are difficult to apply to modernity,
which is just so fundamentally different
than what it was until relatively
recently. The, the,
the key period here in time history is
the last 200 to 250 years when the world
really has changed beyond all recognition.
So in a weird way, are we almost,
we as humans, are we almost
victims of our own success? I mean,
that's sort of what it sounds like.
Like we've, we've done so much good.
We have advanced so far that now were
we mitt picco about little things
constantly and think they're massive
when, yeah, we're not dying of mass.
We're, we're doing a lot with disease,
which we're going to get two and,
and a whole bunch of other things.
We've made our lives way
safer and extended our lives
and all of these things.
So we're almost a victim of
all of that. Goodness. Yes.
So from an evolutionary perspective,
again, the research of others,
not my own overreaction to a
potentially bad thing happening head,
a lower cost to the organism,
in this case,
a human being than under reaction.
Um,
if you overreacted, uh, saw something
that may have been potentially harmful,
you all reacted to it,
but, but you survived.
Whereas if you under reacted to something
that was potentially harmful, then,
uh, your gene pool ended
right there and then, yeah.
So those genes that didn't get
passed on, so yeah. So, so yes. Um,
um, the complexity of
the modern economy, um,
the complexity of the social interactions,
um,
global trading system for
example, is, uh, certainly, um,
uh, much greater than what
our ancestors were exposed to.
And so it is, um, perhaps not
surprising that a lot of people are,
um, uh, little be a little bit
uneasy or continue to be uneasy.
Then again,
the website is there to show
people precisely how bad
things were before and how
good things are now. So don't
get depressed, um, too much.
Um, there is a good story to
be told about humanity. Yeah,
it's interesting when
I go speak at colleges,
one of the lines that I think does
actually work with young people who are,
you know,
if they're protesting and
they're screaming about
the patriarchy and evils of
capitalism and all of this stuff,
I'll always say to them, you know,
does anyone in this room not have
it better than their grandparents?
And certainly in the United States,
but if you live in the western world,
basically everybody does pretty much.
I've yet to find someone that doesn't.
And I always think that's really
effective way of getting people who,
who are so focused on the negative to go,
oh, something good must have happened.
Because, you know, even though I like
to, to scream about my victim hood,
it's a lot better than what my
grandparents had. Yes. I mean take, uh,
something like,
uh,
like a women's equality or gay quality
or even caring about the environment and
uh, and um, uh, and animal rights
or animal welfare, I should say.
Um, Jonathan Heit from, uh, um,
New York University says that capitalism
actually fundamentally transforms,
uh, our, uh, sense of values. Um,
um,
because or priorities I should maybe say,
because when we are extremely poor,
uh,
which is to say the first
99.9% of Homo sapiens on earth,
right? Um, uh, the, the,
the primary objective of any individual
human being was, was to survive.
You had to somehow get hold of enough
calories to make it to the next day.
You had to somehow avoid being murdered
by somebody who wanted your stuff.
Yeah. Um, uh, you had to
somehow protect your family.
You had to keep away from
cold, from heat, et cetera.
But in the last 200 years or so,
our incomes have skyrocketed. Uh,
the world is roughly speaking,
adjusted for inflation.
I can't say this often enough because
we'll always have that, oh God,
you're not adjusting for that course.
We are adjusting for inflation
adjusted for inflation.
The World Everage is roughly 12
times better off than what it was in,
uh, in 1820. So we have
become much richer.
And when you no longer have to
worry about things like survival,
you start caring about
things, uh, like, um,
the nature of the society
that you live in. Uh,
the fairness of treatment of
your fellow human beings. Uh,
you start caring about women equality,
as I said,
you'll start caring about gay rights.
You start caring about animal protection
and environmental protection. So,
um, uh, so in that sense, um, the, the,
the tremendous increase in incomes and,
and general wealth of this society has
also contributed to creating and much
fairer and much more egalitarian society.
So capitalism isn't all evil
is now what you're telling me.
People who think Adelson,
Sh, uh, is evil. I,
I highly recommend that they visit Cuba.
They visit Venezuela,
either visited North Korea
in countries which have,
which have taken deliberately a
step in the opposite direction. Um,
capitalism has its problems.
Uh,
liberal democracy has his problems
and it is our task to try to fix these
problems on the margins.
Uh,
but to throw out the economic and
social underpinnings of modernity,
of this, of this extraordinary
age of abundance, uh,
would be a mistake.
Are you shocked at the amount of people
in the West that seemingly want to do
just that? Um, no. Uh,
I'm much,
I'm not in a shocked by the fact that
in eastern Europe where I'm from,
um,
uh,
people who are in their early
teens and into the late teens,
p people who have never
experienced communists and
people who are born after the
fall of the Berlin Wall are now embracing
socialist ideas,
or at least those socialist ideas are
now increasingly popular amongst young
people. Which day, which is certainly
our, and amongst people of my generation.
What do you chalk that up to you?
Cause I don't think it's just that they
didn't experience is it, is it, is it,
is it just that Utopian dream that we
all have or is it just that it all sounds
good?
The endless cry of equality,
which of course it never turns out
to be equality. It all is just,
if you don't want to really deeply think
about a system or then communism or
socialism is, is pretty good.
Well, not to say that, uh,
that every generation needs to be
educated in the benefits of freedom.
And I think that even filing fighters,
we're talking about something about, uh,
you know, uh, we are always one
generation away from, from tyranny.
Now what that meant was to say that
there is something perhaps
in human nature, um,
that drags us back into that,
um,
into that tribal socialistic mindset.
Now,
there are a lot of theories about that.
One possible theory is that
actually as we grow up,
we grow up in a,
uh,
in the only functioning communist,
a communist society or communist
institution, which is the family.
Hmm. Um, in a family,
especially a nuclear family, uh,
people share wildly. Um,
children are not expected to,
uh, earn a, their
breakfast, uh, by, uh, um,
um, I dunno, bringing home the
Bacon or whatever, you know,
things get chair very, very equally
and so forth. And, and that can work,
um, on a, on a sort of
nuclear family level,
the further you go, the
less it works. I mean,
what you are prepared to do for
your children is not the same,
which you are prepared
to do for your cousins.
It's not the same what you are
prepared to do for your second cousins,
for your fellow citizens
and for that matter,
for people on the opposite side of
the world. And so, uh, the, the,
the fact that we are able
to conduct our affairs,
um, uh, on, on a, uh, along these,
along these socialist lines,
uh, in, in nuclear family, um,
doesn't then translate into,
into the society as a whole.
So that may be one reason. Another
reason may be that, that, um,
um, there is some within human
beings within human psychology,
a tendency to want to bring down
people who have gotten too far up.
If you're thinking about
tribal society, uh, or,
or these roaming groups of
hunter gatherers of say,
between 50 and 150 people,
um, where everybody, uh,
you didn't want all the women and all
the food to be monopolized by the one
alpha male. So the, usually there
was some sort of a combination of,
of an alliance made by other males
to bring this up on the hill down.
So there would be a greater sharing.
And,
and that was good for the
Alpha male too, right? I mean,
he wanted to survive himself and if he
survived it, it's all right. I mean,
I mean in, in, uh, amongst the
chimps and, uh, uh, so forth. The,
the Alpha male that's
usually and very poorly.
Um, so that may be another reason
and other reasons maybe that, uh,
in the hunter gathering society,
some of the food would be shared equally.
There was,
for example, if you killed an animal,
uh, there was no refrigeration.
You couldn't store it. There wasn't no
accumulation of wealth in that sense. Uh,
and so things did get shared amongst
the members of the group. Uh,
plus there wasn't no accumulation
of wealth because, um,
because you are constantly moving,
so whatever your acquired was limited to
whatever you were able to carry on the
back, on your back. Yeah. Um, so yes,
the differences between people,
um,
at least to the extent that
we are experiencing now, uh,
is something that is probably quite
new from an evolutionary standpoint.
So all of these reasons,
um, ensure that, um, and,
and many more ensure that young people
or rather every generation needs to be
explicitly educated in why,
uh,
the economy that we have today,
which is so different from
what our ancestors have
experienced is actually good
for us. Free trade is a
very good example. Um, uh,
free trade contributes to
economic growth, and yet, uh, um,
every generation you have a new
push for protectionism. Again,
the complexity of the economy has outpaced
our ability to understand it without
explicit learning. Yeah. All right.
So let's talk about a whole bunch of
these trends that are happening right in
front of our eyes, but as you said,
they're happening incrementally,
so people don't necessarily
focus on them enough. Uh, well,
I'll let you kick off the person.
What do you,
what do you think is the most encouraging
worldwide trend at the moment?
Or what's exciting you the most proud?
Well,
so the human progress is
unabashedly unabashedly about, uh,
it's a huge human centric,
uh,
which is to say that would be considered
the welfare and the flourishing of a
human being. All human
beings, uh, to be, uh,
to be a really important
of primary importance.
That's an interesting distinction because
you didn't call it earth progress dot
or a great,
I mean,
the idea was that this is so that
humans can figure out the best place,
the best way to live here, and
hopefully that's good for the earth too.
But that humans actually our number one
here, yes, we can certainly talk, um,
late and to show about,
uh,
is it possible for humans to coexist
with the earth and the animals and,
and what can we do to make sure
that that actually happens?
But human progress is a
humanistic project and, um,
uh,
clearly there is no more fundamental
aspect of human flourishing than staying
alive. And, uh, here, uh,
we have seen tremendous improvement.
Um,
prior to 18 hundreds,
uh,
life expectancy around the world was
anywhere between 25 and 30 years.
Since time in memorial,
uh, as late as 1950, sorry,
as late as 1900 in the richest
countries of the world,
life expectancy was only 50 years.
Today,
globally, it's 70 years in
do United States is 78 years.
And in places like Japan, it's 88 years.
So wait, let's, let's not gloss over that.
Cause those were some powerful numbers.
So in 1900 the average life
expectancy was 50 years.
So been in rich countries,
in rich countries enrich galleries,
that's even more impressive, so to
speak. How we've advanced it. So you're,
you're saying basically in the hundred
20 years since then or so we've extended
it by 20 years of being slain
by, so two years in, in the west,
in rich countries, and
by about, and, and, and,
and every person today say somebody
living in Malaysia lives 20 years longer
than rich people did in 1900.
Yeah, that's incredible.
So in 120 years in,
in rich western countries,
we extended life 30 years in 120
days. I mean, that's, that's,
that's almost unfathomable actually.
Uh, it's, it's, it's wonderful.
And so that's the first thing is
that people want to stay alive. Um,
because they, they, they enjoy it. Yeah.
Can you give me some of the markers
of how we actually did that? Well, uh,
one thing is decline in violence,
which again, Steven pinker has.
I switched on the whole book
about, um, um, uh, you know,
um,
rates of people dying in wars.
I have a have declined certainly since
the end of the Second World War. Um,
today for the first time in human history,
uh,
there is no hot conflict between two
states that have declared war on each
other.
So we still have a frozen conflict
between North Korea and the United States.
Uh, we have, uh, we have the Russian
invasion of the eastern Ukraine,
but even then, Russia and Ukraine
are not officially at war.
So there's this old concept
of two countries, you know,
declaring war on each other and then
going towards this actually has actually,
well at this stage it has
disappeared. Yeah. Um,
but almost be unfathomable these days
were two warring countries with full on
wars were invading each other
in the traditional sense.
It would almost be hard to imagine
what that would look like. Now.
That is very awkward cause that,
yeah. Um, hopefully it stays that way.
One thing to remember about,
about,
about human progress is that there
is nothing predetermined about it.
It is not linear. There are obviously
things which can go terribly wrong.
Uh,
the 20th century,
you have the first world war and possibly
the most unnecessary major conflict,
uh, in, in recent centuries,
uh, followed by, uh,
the Second World War and the Holocaust,
the Gulag and what have you.
But the remarkable thing about human
progress and humanity as a whole,
it's, is that at this quite robust,
at the end of the 20th century,
life expectancy are still longer than
what it was at the beginning of the 20th
century.
We are still consuming more calories,
more people went to school
and so on and so forth.
In spite of the 20th century of being
actually quite violent anyhow, since the,
since the end of the Second World War,
a world has gotten progressively
more peaceful. Then of course,
you have medical breakthroughs.
Um,
let's pause on the violence part for
just a second because I think it's one of
those things where you can say that to
people and you can talk all about the
wars that don't exist anymore
and that there are, you know,
genocides the way they were
in on all of those things.
It thus though admitting that some
bad things are still happening,
I think people just don't buy it.
They,
they see school shootings or they see,
you know,
a riot here or something happening
all over the place and they just
automatically believe
things are getting worse.
That sort of gets us to where we started
about how technology is a part of this.
But how difficult is that for you just
to get the truth across to people and
have them actually accept it while
at the same time they are looking at,
you know, a shooting or this or that, that
they can just quickly see online. Yeah.
You've got to look at the longterm trends
and try to figure out whether things
in fact are getting worse
or whether this is a blip.
Um, you know, the line of
progress, again, it's not linear,
it his jacket and um,
and there is no, uh, uh,
once again, there's no
guarantee that, uh, that,
that things will continue to improve.
So you have to look at long term trends.
I think the Atlantic around a story a
few months ago after the latest a school
shooting showing that actually the number
of kids dying at schools horrible as
it is. Yeah. Um, have
been on a decline. Um,
so yeah, so longterm trends. Um,
and then having journalists actually
reported those long term trends that,
that that would be key. Yeah. So,
so violence is one thing we'll
live in less violent times.
The second thing is that the medical
breakthroughs were absolutely fundamental.
Uh, and here I would point simply to
two things. One was vaccination. Um,
a guy called Jenner and Mitt,
I believe mid 18th century England
north that milkmaids didn't get,
uh, didn't get a small box of smallpox
was absolutely horrifying disease.
I mean your body would be
covered with these, um,
with these youth hostels and,
and you know,
80% of kids who got it dyed a up to
60% of adults who got it, who died,
you know, died, uh, in, in
the 18th century, France,
it was estimated 95% of the population
got smallpox at one point of their lives
or another, and gender notice that
milkmaids didn't get smallpox.
That's because they got a milder
version of the POCs from cars.
And so he started inoculating
people with the POCs from the cow.
And because the Latin
word for cow is a vodka,
our word vaccination come some from that.
And that was a major improvement.
The other thing that happened was, um, uh,
was at humanity discovered
the germ theory of disease.
Um,
we didn't know that disease
will spread via germs.
People had all sorts of weird ideas
about humors in the body and mia somatic
theories and what have you.
And it was all nonsense. Uh,
but the upshot of as being so ignorant
about how disease spreads or is that
people, for example, didn't
wash their hands. Uh,
you can imagine,
right?
Farmer is using human
excrement in order to Fel,
fertilize his fields and comes
home and sits down to dinner.
And you can imagine what sort
of diseases literally now, um,
Jews, funny enough who
washed their hands, uh,
as part of their religious
rituals at penny to fall, uh,
less sick and die at a lower
rate than the rest of the,
of the European population.
But once again,
because people are so ignorant
about how these easy spread,
they assumed it wasn't magic,
which again led to pogroms and
discrimination against the Jews. But,
um, even doctors, uh, didn't, um,
doctors also didn't change their clothes,
uh,
because the more blood and Gore
you head on your clothes, uh,
the more it's signified to the potential
patient that you are a doctor in great
demand. Right? So, so, so doctorates,
we're actually a massive,
a reason or on one of the major
reasons why disease spread.
They went from their second
corpses to delivering babies,
introducing pathogen into,
into, into the body of a, uh,
of a mother and a,
and all that stopped basically after,
uh,
a discovery of the germ theory
of disease. Uh, and, and, uh, uh,
child mortality,
maternal mortality started to decline and
life expectancy showed up as a result.
Yeah. What else is going on with
the diseases of today that we're,
we're getting close to eradicating some
things that still exist, right. Well,
we are very close to eradicating polio.
Uh,
there are some what's called wild
cases of polio in, uh, in, uh,
places like the Congo. Um, uh,
of course we have, we have, uh,
made HIV aids, uh, or
rather we have, we have, uh,
created drugs that no longer
make HIV AIDS death sentence.
Um, which, you know,
considering it only took a from 1981 when
we first started talking about HIV age
to about 1994,
1995,
when the first antiretroviral
drugs came along, uh,
only 14 or 15 years, uh, that, that sort
of marketable accomplishment. I mean,
people have lived with small bugs for
a millennia. Um, so we have, we have,
we were able to do that.
Now the other thing which is quite
extraordinary is that cancer rates are
declining. Now, the reason why
that's so interesting is that
incidentally of cancer increased with age.
So as people grow older and on average
we continue to to increase our life
expectancy, the chances of you contracting
or developing cancer, not contracting,
but developing cancer get much
higher. Cancer is basically just, um,
cells dividing, uh, during
a normal process, um,
of, of human body, um, uh, existing.
Uh, but, uh, the more
subdivision of cells you get,
the more likely it is that one of
them is going to go crazy and start
subdividing without control and
cause cancer and you're going to die.
And the fact that cancer rates for men
and women are declining certainly in rich
countries, even though life
expectancy shooting up,
that's again an extraordinary,
um, an extraordinary achievement.
Um, because of early detection,
because of better drugs. Now
with Crispr cas nine, the um,
the gene editing, uh, system, uh,
we are probably going to be able
to focus on personalized medicines.
So we are going to be able to create
drugs specifically for one individual or
group of individuals who share. Um, can,
can you explain CRISPR a little bit
just for those that are, you know,
you don't have to give
you a major equation,
but like the sort of the most
simple explanation of it.
I was reading something on the side of
the today about CRISPR. Yeah. Well it's,
it's, it's a gene editing technique,
uh, which is to say that, uh,
hypothetically, and hopefully we're
not very far from, from that. Uh,
from that time you'll be able
to splice out of the genome, uh,
to cut out from the genome,
uh,
genes which are responsible
for a congenital diseases,
uh, which would be, uh, which
would be a very nice, uh,
it would be very nice to know
that if a child gets born,
it will develop multiple sclerosis,
uh, 20 years down the line and die in,
in terrible pain.
So these are the sorts of things that
we could do it with CRISPR. Yeah. Uh,
I want to move on to the environment,
but is there anything else on
the mathematical data? I mean,
education is the obvious, uh,
example. Uh, obviously, uh,
80% of the world is literate.
What is most of the time people
were not literate on those?
Now a gender parity between
boys and girls? Pretty much, uh,
on average in the world. Uh, again,
something to be happy about
because historically, uh,
girls were kept from education at
a higher rate than boys. I mean,
even in Afghanistan and now,
uh,
girls are allowed to go to school,
which again, is a wonderful thing.
And nutrition, I would, I would
really like to end with nutrition,
which is to say that,
um,
famine has disappeared from
the world outside of war zones.
We all remember those images
of starving children, um,
with inflated Belize in
Ethiopia, the early 1980s. Yeah.
And, um, uh, that's,
that's pretty much uh,
disappeared and, um, um, uh,
hunger was basically a normal human
condition throughout our history and,
uh, today, um,
and every African consumes
as many calories as the
Portuguese did in the early
1960s.
Just about everywhere in the world,
people are consuming more calories than,
uh,
than what the USDA recommends,
should be the average intake.
And in, in Africa, they are
certainly reaching that threshold.
And Africa is important because that's
really where absolute poverty, um,
continues to be a major problem. Um, I,
I think it's fair to say that
absolute poverty is going to,
is ending as a global problem. It
is now going to remain as a, as a,
as a, uh, as an African problem. Um,
that is concentrated in a couple
of African country in, in,
in a few African countries, including
places like the Congo. All right,
so let's shift to the environment.
You listened to the news.
It's getting hotter.
Everybody's freaking out about everything.
We don't have clean water.
All of these things
calm me down. Well, I don't want to
get into a debate. It's a debate over,
over the signs of, of global warming.
I'll leave it to the specialist. Um,
certainly I do acknowledge that there is
a consensus that the world is warming.
Uh,
whether it is warming at a,
at a too high a rate or a lukewarming
rate and where it is heading.
Obviously prediction of the future is
that that's the most difficult thing.
I'm going to leave that to, to a
specialty center scientists. Yeah.
Just very quickly on that though,
is it possible that in some of
the places that it's warming,
it's actually good that it's warming?
Well, a, suddenly this, this, uh,
this one scientist from Holland
called a professor tall,
has a calculated, uh, the,
the likely costs and benefits of
global warming until 2080 or so.
And he thought that, uh, um,
because of the growing, uh,
because of the longer growing season,
we'll be able to actually bring in, uh,
more, uh, more and more
food grow, grow more food.
We also thought that,
uh,
there is also some evidence that the world
is greening as a result of more a CEO
two in the atmosphere. But I do
acknowledge I want to make it very,
yeah.
Any hate mail to you or to me,
I want to go into get hate mail either
way. Right. Acknowledge way acknowledged
that, uh, uh, there are
serious concerns. Um, uh,
and, and I'm, I'm basically a
guy who is a techno optimist.
I want to look for
solutions to these problems,
uh,
rather than what I don't want to
do is to stop economic development.
I don't want to stop economic development
in developing countries because it's
extremely important that,
that people who are very,
very poor should not be very,
very poor.
It's very important that if a woman
in Angola or in Zambia has a premature
birth, she should be able
to have an access to a, uh,
to an incubator that is a run on a,
on a,
uh, on an electricity grid
that is not going to collapse,
for example, okay. That, uh, that
people can air condition their homes,
let's say in Africa or that they can,
they can keep themselves warm in a,
in Argentina basically, that, that is my,
my goal not to stop economic development,
um,
those particularly of true
of, um, of, of poor countries.
Uh, but I also think that it
applies to rich countries. Um,
if, if we can make life more
comfortable for people. I, I see, no,
I think it would be very difficult,
especially within the democratic
context context to stop that.
Now look at what's happening in,
uh, in macrons Paris. We've seen
riots, yeah. That country has and hasn't
seen since the 1960s. Why is that?
That's because the environmental concerns
of the French elite micron included
are bumping against, uh, the, uh,
living standards and limitations on the
living standards of ordinary French men
and women.
If you increase the price of electricity,
uh, dramatically in order to make
people cut down on electricity,
it's also going to reduce their,
their, both their comfort,
but also their standard of living.
If you're going to put additional taxes
on this, that, and the other cars, uh,
gasoline, what have you, uh,
eventually people are going to get upset
and are going to start voting for some
very unpleasant people.
And this is something that we see
happening throughout Europe. Now.
There are many different reasons why
people vote for, um, uh, for unpleasant,
uh, of political parties. But, uh, a,
a fundamental feeling that that
standards of living in Europe,
art stagnating and that they are being
taxed to a point where they actually have
to go out and protest in
the streets, burn, uh,
hundreds of cars and basically
vandalized the Arc de Triomphe. Okay. So,
so these things are happening.
So what I want to do is to sort of
navigate a middle course between,
uh, between concerns over the
environment, uh, and uh, and uh,
and continued economic development
and continued prosperity.
And I think that the answer
could potentially be found
in, um, techno optimism,
as I would call it.
So I would consider a fracking to be a
good example of taking our optimism. Okay.
Uh,
burning of one unit of natural gas
produces half as much co two emissions as
burning of coal [inaudible].
So I think it would make a lot of sense
to burn more natural gas than coal.
But
a friend's on the environmental side hate
that because it's still fossil fuels.
Okay. So let's forget about fossil
fuels. Let's have nuclear energy.
Okay. Last time anybody has died from a
nuclear accident, it was ensure no bill.
Um, because the communist leadership, uh,
cut corners when it came to the safety
and, uh, there was a breakdown of,
of um, chain of command and
whatever. And there wasn't this,
this accident where a, where dozens
of people died, but since then,
not a single person has died as
a result of nuclear accidents,
including in Fukushima, which
is the most recent one. Um,
so nuclear energy is a perfect
example of producing a lot of energy,
uh, without any CEO. Two emissions.
Are Our friends in the environmentalist
movement please? No, they are not.
Let's take another example. Um, uh,
say a photo Leiser.
Let's say that we can genetically
engineer crops to need less fertilizer and
less pesticides.
Why do we want a less
fertilizer and less pesticides?
Because when those flow into
rivers and then into oceans,
they can have a negative
consequence for wildlife.
So ideally we would like to use
less fertilizer, less pesticide.
So imagine that through Gmos,
uh, through genetic engineering,
we could produce crops that, uh, that,
that don't require pesticides and
fertilizer are our friends in the
environmental, I'll be happy. No, they
hate, they hate those three letters.
In the time that we offer
as techno optimists,
we offer a gradual move
in the right direction,
which cumulatively could have a
massive impact on quality of life,
on the environmental
protection and so forth. Um,
you know, the, the, the
answer is always no. So what,
so it's interesting because when
you started talking about this,
there's this immediate hesitancy
because I think everyone,
if you talk about climate at all,
people think you're going to get slammed.
And I can tell you the most hate that I
ever got on the show was when I had Alex
Epstein on wrote a book called the
moral case for fossil fuels in there.
He wasn't denying climate science. He
was, you're saying that fossil fuels,
in his estimation,
are still the best way to advance
human prosperity going forward.
So it's interesting you,
you immediately said you didn't want
to go too far down that road because it
just opens up the the hate and
all that, but, but in essence,
what you're saying is that we're having
to fight the environmentalist's on what
you would prescribe as the best ways
to move the environment forward.
That that's pretty fascinating. So how do
you get through to these people then? I,
well, I don't know. I'm trying,
what are the things I'm trying to
explain to a lot of my friends is that
actually prosperity and
economic development can be
a friend of the environment.
That's because of this concept
of environmental Kuznets curve.
Now that's just a fancy way of
saying that when people grow richer,
they are willing to spend more money
on clean environment and protection of
animals. How do I know
that? Because in in,
well it's not just stats which show it,
but also look at the real life examples.
When do you kind of me
collapsed in Zimbabwe?
The first thing that people did in order
to survive was to start slaughtering
animals in the wild,
shooting zebras for meat,
shooting elephants for tusks. Um, and,
and the environment took a huge knock
in Venezuela when the economy collapsed.
Both socialist countries by the way,
but you never mind in Venezuela
when the economy collapsed,
uh, people started slaughtering
animals in the zoo.
The only way you can survive if it's a
choice between the life of an antelope
and the survival of your child,
you know exactly what to do.
And so economic development,
making people richer,
it's actually,
um,
a very good way of accomplishing
this environmental co Kuznets curve.
When people grow rich, they start
caring about the air they breathe,
they start caring about a welfare
of animals and so on and so forth.
Because those are from the perspective
of the survival of the human being.
Luxury goods.
And we are already seeing some very
interesting things happening around the
world. For example, the
forest coverage of, uh, of,
of,
of the Oris is still declining
by about 0.08% per year,
but it is declining primarily,
if not exclusively in poor countries and
especially in Africa and also like an
American,
but it is increasing in a rich countries,
uh, for a station is they can place
their more forest being grown.
And in China, uh, we are
seeing huge amount of our,
for a station because the country is now
Richard than what did you used to be.
So through economic development, we can
do that through economic development.
We can also, um, uh,
we can also start protecting
more of our marine life, um,
by creating exclusion zones, uh,
against fishing and so forth.
How can we do that? Why is that
connected to economic development? Well,
because if you're, for
example, you can, well,
not only do you have more
technological, um, uh,
ways of monitoring who
is breaking the rules,
but also you can still get access to
the food you want through aquaculture.
Okay. So countries which are richer, uh,
are able to,
uh,
are able to get their food from,
from aquaculture rather than from,
uh, from ordinary, uh, shore fishing.
So when, when it comes to these
solutions, which, by the way, I mean,
what you just said there,
it's pretty mind blowing that in much
of the world it's getting greener.
You know, I mean, that's, people just
don't think about that. We just sorted,
just don't accept that.
That's real. Most of this.
Do you see that we have
to have a, a sort of, uh,
public and private partnership on
how we move forward on these things?
Should most of this come from governments?
Should it come from private corporations?
Should it come from individual people?
I mean, that seems to be what a lot
of the debate is also about. Well, uh,
I think that the research that
the, um, uh, evidence, uh,
for the efficacy of a government
spending when it comes to a science,
um, w when it comes to
scientific research, for example,
is it's not all that persuasive.
I don't think that governments are
particularly good at spending money on
scientific research.
Um,
meaning that the researcher shoddy or
just that they throw money at things and
then just nothing comes of it. Um,
yeah, that, that, that would be,
that will be part of reason.
Um, I am a believer in, uh,
in, uh, in, uh, private companies
doing their own research,
um, driven by the profit
motive, for example.
Um,
energy inputs into production
of anything from a can of coke,
two bottle of water. Uh, our costs money.
A companies actually do have a,
an incentive at profit incentive to try
to limit the amount of resources they
use in order to produce any type of good.
Um,
in the 1970s,
uh,
between 1970s and today,
the number of cans of coke that you
could get from a pound of aluminum has
actually increased by something like 40%.
That's because companies
don't want to spend money.
They don't have to spend on
electricity, uh, on, uh, uh,
spending money on natural resources and
will and raw materials and wood heavy.
And so what we are actually
seeing is that, uh,
the number of dark dollars, um, uh, per,
um, uh, what the,
the amount of the amount of energy we
need in order to produce a dollar of
output is actually declining.
And that that's happening naturally
through the process of profit maximization
on the parts of,
of corporations.
Now that doesn't mean that there is
absolutely no need for any kind of
regulations.
We don't want corporations to be,
to be dumping toxic materials in our
pristine rivers and what have you.
But, uh, uh, but what I am
saying is that, uh, is that uh,
corporations in search for profit,
um,
are actually very good at coming up with
innovative solutions to environmental
problems.
Yeah.
It's part of the problem here also
that different countries that are at
different stages of their evolution of
their economies and everything else need
different things,
need wildly different things.
What's happening in China now with
growth is very different than what's
happening in the United States or,
or India or any of these
countries that now half, half to,
that are often putting out more co two
and emissions and things like that.
They're going through their
industrial revolutions.
We already did it so that
we have an unequal playing
field when it comes to some
of them. Yes. Um, so
that is a well known, uh,
notion within economic development
that, uh, as a country, uh,
starts on a pass to industrialization.
It's a them should environment increases.
But once again, it reaches that, uh,
that inflection point and then it
starts to decrease as people become rich
enough to start to appreciate,
um, nice environment. Um,
90% of the plastics that are entering
our oceans come from eight rivers are all
in the developing world,
in Africa and in Asia. Uh,
the contribution of western advanced
economies to plastic pollution of the
oceans is negligible,
um,
precisely because we are able to spend
more money and effort and thought on how
not to do it. What would you say
to the people that would say, uh,
our time is up here?
Or the evolution of humanity is
that we've got to go to the stars,
that eventually we'll have to get off
this mortal coil and do it again somewhere
else. Well, uh, first of all,
it is very important to remember that
a pessimism about humanity's future,
uh, has been with us since
the, since the dawn of writing,
um, um, from,
from antiquity and ancient
poems and epics. You know, the,
the afternoon, the flood, what is
it about the flood is about closing.
The world's depressing, the
relation that, that, uh, that went,
uh, all right. Um,
the Cato, the elder, uh,
writing second century BC thoughts
that Rome was finished because,
um, you know, uh, the, the, the
young were corrupted and, uh,
um,
women had loose morals and men
were to feminists to fight wars.
And this is when Rome was just
a small town in, you know,
with fewer, uh, with a
few provinces in Italy.
Rome continue to expand for the
next three to 400 years. Um,
but he was just very early.
He was just very early. Uh,
but you can see every generation
thinks that, that, that we are,
especially as we grow
older, we think that, uh,
the world is entering a period of decline.
Whereas in fact what we are doing,
we are projecting our own physical
decline, uh, onto the world.
But so far those,
uh,
those warnings about the imminent collapse
of humanity have always been proven
wrong. As, um, uh, Thomas
Babington Macaulay, uh,
in 19th century British politician
and the writer has written on,
on what basis is it without having seen
all this progress that we have made
behind us.
We see nothing but misery in front of us.
I'm paraphrasing,
but that's the essence of what he said
and I think he's absolutely right. Yeah.
So we've,
we've done the diseases,
we're eradicating,
we're doing a lot of good on the
environment or at least have,
have some options now.
Yes. Yeah. Uh, what else, what else should
we be hitting on to give people some,
some positivity to think
about? Well, I think, um,
my pet peeve is a, that I think that, uh,
people don't read enough history,
aren't enough versed in, uh, in,
in history how life really
used to be like, uh, before.
Um,
and I wish that people would spend more
time thinking about what they are doing
on their base daily basis
and asking themselves, uh,
would I be able to do this in the past?
Um,
I just had a crown,
uh,
have put in or a root canal operation
with anesthetic. And it was,
it was not something and there wasn't
a particularly pleasant, but, but,
but it was better than it would
have been a hundred years ago.
A hundred or 200 years ago. You
would have it, you know, um,
somebody would have to pull it
out of your, out of your mouth.
Um, and, um, um, so, so,
so that's the one thing.
Uh, I think that people, uh,
and I think that if people understand
history better and how life truly was
quite horrific until very recent
times, again, we are 300,000 years old,
but at the time of abundance,
it's roughly 200 years old,
250 years old. Maybe there will
be more grateful and um, uh,
for the things that we have and hopefully
they will be more appreciative and
more supporting of the institutions
which underpin a modernity,
liberal democracy with all of its warts,
with all of its imperfections.
It is still functioning better
than a Putin is Russia or,
or the Turkey.
A free market.
Capitalism does have
its problems. Yes. Um,
we shouldn't socialize costs
of banking for example,
and prioritized and privatized
gains from Wall Street banking.
Um, but again, it is the best.
It is the best creative
known to humankind.
And so throwing it out because there
are imperfections on the margins that we
should be working on to, to, to
improve would be a great mistake. Um,
so yes, appreciation of the
past, gratitude for the present,
hopefulness for the future.
Um, those are the steps in,
I think,
in the right direction that my friend
is an a plus ending to an interview and
for more on Marriott and the incredible
work that think progress is doing.
You guys can check out thing progress.org.